the Senate could vote as early as next
week on its plan to repeal and replace
the Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare but the overall faces a big
challenge Nevada Republican Dean Heller
became the fifth GOP senator to declare
his opposition that's enough to sink the
measure
unless Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
can turn some of them around
president Trump supports the bill but
investigations surrounding the White
House continue to bogged down his agenda
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the latest Darrell good morning good
morning as questions swirl over the
Russia investigations the White House is
letting President Trump do what he does
best speak for himself and in an
interview Friday the president made
clear his opinions on the FBI director
he fired and the special counsel he's
worried about I don't have any tape and
I didn't take president Trump directly
denied recording his conversations with
former FBI director James Comey the
president suggested his May 12th tweet
which first mentioned potential tapes
sent a message to the ousted FBI
director when he found out that I you
know that there may be tapes out there
whether it's governmental tapes or
anything else and who knows
I think his story may have changed when
asked if Special Counsel Robert Muller
should recuse himself from the ongoing
Russia investigation the president
offered concerns was very very good
friends with Comey which is very
bothersome I can say that the people
that have been hired are all Hillary
Clinton supporters lately mr. Trump has
been acting as his own spokesperson
while White House press briefings have
become more restricted Fridays was audio
only I don't think that the be-all and
end-all is whether it's on television or
not I'd rather sit here and have a very
enjoyable conversation with you on
issues on a Friday afternoon after and
let the president's comments stand the
White House wants more attention paid to
its productivity holding a signing
ceremony showing President Trump
strengthening accountability measures at
the VA
and working with Congress to repeal and
replace Obamacare but that effort may be
in jeopardy as a fifth Republican
senator announced public opposition
Friday to the Senate's current aversion
this bill this bill is currently in
front of the United States Senate not
the answer it's simply not the answer
now the White House says the president
is very supportive of the current bill
that mr. Trump is in contact with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell and that
mr. Trump may be in contact with
concerned GOP members in the next few
days to shore up those all-important
votes Dana
time is ticking Errol Barnett at the
White House thank you